et autres manifestations aujourd'hui
celle des étudiants une mobilisation à
l'appel d'une dizaine d'organisations
syndicales et politiques de gauche pour
protester contre les difficultés des
jeunes fortement impacté par les mesures
de restrictions sanitaires
les syndicats réclament à un plan
d'urgence d'un million cinq cent mille
euros avec entre autres une augmentation
immédiate des bourses et des apl
réaction de manifestants et de politique
au micro de katia pique nique la
situation des jeunes est dramatique et
la situation des jeunes étudiants aussi
il ya déjà le fait de subvenir à ses
moyens
on est très étonné que le gouvernement
hésite encore à mettre en place le rsa
jeunes qui devrait être la situation de
crise qu'on connaît une évidence il ya
le fait opposition toujours très
compliqué vis-à-vis du zaire site et on
pense qu'elle devrait réouvrir
et puis c'est pas les quelques mesures
mis en place par le gouvernement
genre les 150 euros qui équivalent à des
à 50 centimes par jour
qui
qui vont changer quoi que ce soit donc
on a toute une jeunesse qui est en train
de plonger et comme beaucoup de chauny
gouvernement n'est pas à la hauteur
il ya de plus en plus de problèmes avec
les lycéens qui en finale n'a plus à
trouver du travail
gagnez de l'argent qui se développe de
plus en plus les associations qui
soi-disant les aider ont du mal à les
aider parce que le confinement les
empêche de survivre vraiment pour lutter
contre la précarité étudiante
j'ai été extrêmement choqué pendant
cette crise sanitaire par l'allongement
des décos devant les centres alimentaire
et la précarité vraiment terrible qui
touche l étudiant donc on est vraiment
là pour demander des mesures fortes au
gouvernement pour l'aja mais il faut
vraiment un vrai plan d'action pour
lutter contre cette précarité étudiante
pour réduire les inégalités entre les
étudiants qui peuvent vivre avec le lait
de leurs parents et ceux qui ne le
peuvent pas les étudiants qui ont besoin
d'un travail pour subvenir à leurs
besoins
rate beaucoup plus de chances de rater
leurs études que les étudiants n'ont pas
besoin et pour ça il faut donc mes
camarades landi prendre des mesures
significatives notamment l'allocation
d'autonomie pour tous les étudiants pour
qu'ils puissent avoir un revenu de base
à ans venu digne